hi I'm Abby sharp and this is what a
registered dietitian eats in a day
obviously we had my soy milk latte and I
had a random piece of fruit and a piece
of cheese on my way to dropping the kids
off at school then I got back home and I
threw on my house uniform AKA my house
coat then I made myself my protein
cereal some protein powder and protein
milk I added lots of different kinds of
cereal some fruit some hemp Parts it is
so damn good and stating for lunch I
made chicken quesadillas and served it
with some basic bagged salad keeping it
super simple and easy on a workday and
for dinner with stir fry I had some
grown turkey lots of veggies some rice
in there some for a khaki on top and
some cashews and then we served it with
some steamed buns and for bedtime snack
I had a bowl of my favorite pink himalay
and sea salt lesser evil popcorn it's so
deliciously good and salty I had a
random craving for some cheese so I had
that with my fiber supplement and the
rest of my bedtime supplements and
medication and I went to bed that's it